مكملين معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه تطورات
الاتهام بالاغتصاب الموجهه للاعب او
اللاعب المنتخب المغربي ونادي باريس سان
جيرمان اشرف حكيمي ففي فتاه توجهت للشرطه
في بلاغ قالت انه مو شكوى ولكن اثبات حاله
وقالت انها بعد ما تكلموا على انستجرام
اشرف يوم 25 فبراير ارسل لها وبرجع بها
البيت وهناك اغتصبها السلطات رغم انه
البنت ما اشتكت لكنها اعلنت فتح تحقيق
قضائي في الموضوع حكيم رد على الاتهامات
عبر بيان لمحاميته وصف الاتهامات بالكاذبه
والباطله واللي ما صارت وبيقول انه مستعد
للتعاون مع السلطات وبيضع نفسه تحت تصرف
العداله
نادي حكيمه اللي هو باريس سان جيرمان هو
كمان علق في اولا تم الاعلان انه هو لازال
في تشكيلات النادي وبيشارك في تدريباته
وممكن يشارك كمان في المباراه الجايه وما
في اي سبب بيمنع هذا الشيء ومصادر في
النادي قالت لوسائل اعلام فرنسيه انه
الخبر صدمها وانها جالسه بتحاول تجمع
معلومات وتفاصيل اضافيه لدعم لاعبها ضد
هذه الاتهامات وقالت انها بتثق في العداله
وانها مؤسسه تشجع الاحترام داخل وخارج
الملعب اما اللي كانت غايبه عن رده الفعل
وكل الانظار مستنيه تعليقها اصلا دون
غيرها فهي زوجه الممثله الاسبانيه هبه عبو
لمولوده لام تونسيه واب ليبي هبه التزمت
الصمت وما شفنا اي تعليق منها على صفحتها
الشخصيه لدعم ولا غيره ويبدو انه السبب في
عدم تعليقها هي الاخبار التي تم تداولها
من الاعلام الاسباني واللي قال انها طالبه
الط رسميا الاخبار بتقول انه زوجه حكيمي
من اسابيع وقبل ما يطلع موضوع الاتهامات
للعلن مقدمه رسميا اوراق الطلاق وانا
وحكيمي منفصلين من فتره والمتداول ان
ابلغت اقارب له انه علاقتهم مو زابطه بسبب
فرق العمر والاولويات فهي بتربي اولاد او
تعمل اسره وهو بس مهتم بالسهر
والانبساط هذا الكلام اللي نقلته صحيفه
فرنسيه او اسبانيه عفوا وبالنسبه للعمر
فهي 36 سنه وحكيمي 24 سنه وهم متزوجين من
ثلاث سنوات تعرفوا في 2018 وتزوجوا في
2020 وفي نفس السنه ولد اول اولادهم اللي
هو امين وفي عشرين 22 انولد الثاني واسمه
نعيم الاخبار اذا بتقول انه في انفصال من
فتره لكن يعني الاتهامات سرعت من الكشف
عنه وادله الانفصال كانت واضحه لانه اولا
الثنائي ما لهم صوره سوا على المنصات من
اكتوبر مع انه الاثنين
نشيطين جدا ثانيا ما حضرت مع حفل توزيع
جوائز ذا بيست التابع للفيفا بل راح حكيم
الحفل مع اخوه وهبه واولادها في اجازه
خارج المغرب من فتره والواقعه اللي بتتكلم
عنها البنت اللي بتتهم حكيمي صارت خيل
وجودهم خارج البلاد وفي منزلهم نفسه
[موسيقى]